as first lady former first lady Michelle
Obama she found herself as one of the
most visible women in the world but
growing up she says she was haunted by
self-doubt that's just one of the
revelations in her new memoir it's
called becoming last night the former
first lady launched her book tour in her
hometown of Chicago with Oprah only on
CBS this morning we spoke backstage to
Oprah about the book and coming home I
got the best night because I get to come
home to Sweet Home Chicago and she is
the south side of Chicago hometown girl
we're back in Chicago and we get to
share that energy with the audience
and I love a good book and I almost
didn't choose this one just because
everybody would say oh yeah of course
you're choosing that book because
Michelle Obama is your friend but the
book was too good not to choose we're
home we're home everybody's story
matters the significance of her story is
that it started with such humble
beginnings but with love and support of
family and that when you have that you
can do just about anything the value of
her story is that it lets everybody know
that your story is equally as valuable
even though you may not make it to the
White House a really good point
everybody's jewelry is valuable that's
the thing about Michelle Obama she's
relatable and inspiring that was part
that was the first book tour kick off
she's going to ten cities here in the
United States and then they're going
national terrorists Oh international
Paris London you know she is very
popular around the world that's correct
those are sold out that's gonna keep
that book at number one long yeah people
want to hear from her a lot of people
hope that's the case in part two of our
conversation Michelle Obama describes
learning that she was not alone and
wondering am I good enough you've been
out of the White House for 606 migraine
how's it going it's going okay I want
people to get a sense Michelle of your
life because my life now your life now
in that first day yeah it's one of those
rare moments I call it toast gate yeah I
think toast gate is this how I open up
the book yeah it's sort of the life that
I was living months after we moved out
of the White House I was alone for the
first time in a long time because for
eight years prior to that I had lived a
life where I was always with somebody
there was always a constant presence in
the White House but that day Barack was
traveling Malia was in college sasha was
somewhere doing something yeah and it
was just me and Bo and sunny my dogs and
I did what I didn't do for eight years
which was open up my own cupboard pull
out some bread and make some cheese
toast
did you remember how to do that I
remember you know I still had cheese
toast skills throughout the book there
was a lot of am I good enough you're
told by a school counselor you're not
Princeton material why didn't it
destroy you at the time well because
fortunately it was the direct opposite
of everything I'd ever been told about
myself I had grown up with love and
support and encouragement and high
expectations but here I walked into this
room with a woman who really didn't know
me because it was a big high school and
she had to make a quick assessment and
her assessment could have been and I
don't know was great for an average
yeah you're a good student you know your
scores are good you're black you're here
in this public school maybe you're
stretching she didn't even know my
brother went to print she didn't ask me
questions about it yeah she didn't try
to figure me out she just decided that
the dream I presented was wrong but let
me tell you we could probably go into
any room of black women or people of
color or people who grew up in poor
communities or rural communities and
you'd ask them as anybody ever told you
you couldn't and everyone would raise
your hand you get to Princeton and one
of the first things you notice is
they're not smarter than me so now I'm
expecting brilliance genius and then
what I discover is wow there's a lot of
arbitrariness to this stuff you know
because while a lot of students are sort
of criticized as a debate about
affirmative action when it comes to race
what I point out is that I got two
prints and I realized there's a hole all
kinds of affirmative action that goes on
there kids who get in because they're
athletes they're kids who get in because
there's a legacy it's just that race
stands out but it was important for me
to see that are you tired of the way the
country is going are you mad enough did
you feel you were judged differently
because you write in the book your grace
would have to be earned you knew that
you you felt you could not stumble man
well I had experienced that over the
course of the campaign I mean I write in
chapter 17 you know that chapter was
probably one of the hardest for me to
write and it's the hardest still for me
to read because it goes over a painful
time in the campaign
when I thought I was doing great telling
my story sharing it honestly but my my
whole persona was distorted this was the
time I was called an angry black woman I
was called Obama's baby's mama I was
called someone who didn't love her
country and I it's important for me to
paint all that because people don't
remember that they see Michelle Obama
now especially young girls and they
don't they don't they were too young to
know that part of my journey let's go
back to angry black woman how did you
process that what did you when you heard
it it's it's like it's painted it's like
the punch in a gut that the counselor it
was another series of punches someone
who judged me without knowing me it was
just happening at a bigger level but I
had to draw on the same foundation of I
cannot let one or two or a few people's
judgments of me control me and at that
point I thought about getting off the
campaign trail and went to Barack Obama
and said yeah I was like look if I'm if
I'm you know I'm not an asset then just
pull me out and he was like no you are
you're the closer you know we need you
out there and so I had to get myself
together I'm gonna have to show the
world that I do belong I am good enough
to be the first lady I do love my
country and just think about this guy's
she said there are no notes about
there's no handbook about being first
lady so she's put on the campaign trail
no notes no talking book points no real
team just her and two other staffers no
speeches they did it all themselves
you know even hair and makeup was all
left to them you know all these things
matter when you're out on the road but
Michelle Obama's ratings are way people
felt about her many times were higher
than Barack Obama's you meet her and you
spend time with her people of all ages
fellowmen and that first lady's role has
never been defined it's always been
something it reflects the person in the
office because as she pointed out to
that doesn't have a snap it doesn't have
a budget they just want to work within
that but I find so fascinating her
talking about self-doubt yes
vulnerability and resilience and I think
that's a universal message
and that off that title becoming
becoming something despite all that
self-doubt and the people who tell you
you're not good enough she ask a lot of
in the book of many times am i enough am
I good enough and I think at the end of
the day she can now say and she believes
yes I am and she worked her way up to be
the closer yeah right because remember
that speech of the high dimension yeah
that the reason she knew she was good
enough was because of her parents those
good pure they saw it oh my gosh so
that's a perfect segue to thank you Nora